good morning Hank it's Thursday
congratulations on your song yesterday
it was your best song ever hang a couple
months ago I did a video that was about
like a day in the life of a writer and
it was me and scott westerfeld's and
Maureen Johnson hanging out in a hotel
room and writing and that was really fun
so I thought I would do a follow-up
called
a day in the life of a writer who
doesn't have any friends so now that
I've moved to Indianapolis what happens
every morning is that I get up and I sit
down in this chair or possibly outside
and the first thing that I do is I
listen to your song god that's a good
song
so after I listen to your song I spend
about 30 minutes missing my old writing
friends from New York so I'll say to
myself I wonder what Scott and Yasin are
doing today they're probably on the
phone probably having a fancy lunch
Maureen's just gotten back from England
I bet she's having some fun probably
right - funny blog post I wish they were
here it's kind of boring
this room echoes echo echo I'm lonely
lonely Hey after all my warm-up is over
I proceeded to do this
and that goes on for about seven hours
the funny thing about writing is that
whether you're doing it well or doing it
poorly it looks the exact same
that's actually one of the main ways
that writing is different from ballet
dancing today I've been working on a
part of my new novel that's about 150
pages in but I thought just for fun I
might read you the prologue since people
in my pants have been spending so much
time debating what my book is about I
thought maybe I would give them the
slightest hint the way I figure it
everyone gets a miracle like I will
probably never be struck by lightning or
become the dictator of a small nation in
the Pacific Islands or contract terminal
ear canal cancer or spontaneously
combust but if you consider all the
unlikely things together at least one of
them will probably happen to each of us
admittedly the world contains a lot of
people but it also contains a lot of
unlikely hoods I could have seen it rain
frogs in my hometown I could have
stepped foot on Mars I could have been
eaten by an orca I could have married
the Queen of England or survived months
at sea but my miracle was different my
miracle was Marvel okay I'll see you
tomorrow and since I won't have a chance
to speak to you again
until you're finished with Harry Potter
I just wanted to say I hope it lives up
to your every expectation I mean if the
book is as good as the song you wrote
then it's going to be one heck of a book